-Elle s'est lancée en politique
à 48 ans, sans aucune expérience,
mais ça ne l'a pas empêchée
d'enchaîner les succès,
jusqu'à être élue députée en 2017,
mais pendant six ans,
elle n'a pas siégé.
Il faut dire qu'elle avait
une bonne raison à cela.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Mme Darrieussecq.
-Bonjour.
-En politique,
quand vous vous êtes engagée
aux côtés de François Bayrou,
à Mont-de-Marsan,
on vous connaissait déjà,
mais pas du tout
pour vos idées politiques.
On vous connaissait
parce qu'on vous voyait sur le bord
du terrain
tous les dimanches,
au Stade Montois,
le club de rugby.
Vous étiez le docteur chargé
de soigner les joueurs.
On va revoir
un extrait d'une prise de parole
de vous à cette époque.
*-Je crois que ce dont
les joueurs ont besoin surtout,
c'est d'être entourés,
de sentir
que personne
ne baisse les bras autour.
*Elle hésite.
Dans le club,
mais aussi à l'extérieur du club.
Je crois
qu'il faut sentir
qu'on est soutenu par le public,
qu'on est soutenu
par la ville où on vit.
-Là, quand on vous entend,
c'était une période difficile
pour le club.
On a l'impression
que vous étiez plus
la psy des joueurs
que la médecin.
-Les médecins,
ils sont toujours là,
dans les clubs
en particulier,
pas que pour soigner
le physique.
Ils sont aussi là
pour soigner le moral,
pour écouter les joueurs
écouter quelquefois les détresses,
écouter les questions.
Donc, ça fait partie du job.
J'ai fait ça
de façon bénévole
pendant 10 ans,
en structurant l'équipe médicale
d'un club professionnel,
d'un club devenu professionnel.
Donc, c'était très passionnant,
et en plus
de mon activité
de médecin allergologue,
je faisais ça,
et ça a été très passionnant.
-Alors, dans une ville
comme Mont-de-Marsan, j'imagine...
Il faut savoir qu'à Mont-de-Marsan,
le rugby, c'est pas rien,
ça compte énormément.
-Oui.
-J'imagine que soigner un peu
les héros de la ville,
c'est la rampe de lancement idéale
pour la politique.
-Ecoutez, oui.
Bon, vous avez de la notoriété,
ça aide, effectivement.
Puis, la notoriété,
c'était pas que moi.
C'était aussi mon mari,
qui était ancien joueur,
kiné de l'équipe,
une grande figure locale.
Donc, si vous voulez,
il a aussi participé avec moi
à toute cette aventure,
ou plutôt,
j'y ai participé
avec lui.
-Là, on vous voit
au milieu des joueurs.
-En définitive...
Oui, ça, c'est l'esprit festif,
et puis c'est toujours
quand on gagne.
C'est une montée en Top 14, ça,
que nous avions gagnée
contre Pau, d'ailleurs, en 2012.
-Alors là...
Moi, j'étais très heureuse,
contrairement à François Bayrou.
-François Bayrou est venu
vous chercher en 2004.
C'était pour les régionales.
A l'époque,
il vous a proposé d'être
tête de liste de l'UDF
dans votre département des Landes,
mais à l'époque,
vous n'aviez jamais mis
les pieds
dans une salle
de meeting politique.
C'est assez incroyable
qu'il vous ait proposé cela.
Pourquoi vous a-t-il choisie ?
-Parce qu'il cherchait
un profil, quelqu'un
qui était connu dans sa ville,
qui était engagé
dans le mouvement associatif
et puis qui avait
une profession...
Médecin,
c'est souvent...
-Il cherchait une femme aussi ?
-Il cherchait
surtout une femme,
pour être tête de liste
dans les Landes.
Je devais cumuler
un petit peu tout cela.
Les choses ont fait
que nous nous sommes rencontrés
et que je n'ai pas pu résister
à sa demande.
-Vous aviez une petite notoriété
liée au rugby, mais vos adversaires
vous ont surnommée "madame X".
C'est vrai ?
-Oui, "madame X".
"Puis, une femme, forcément,
elle sait pas faire,
"elle a pas de compétences.
"Si elle n'a jamais été là,
elle va pas y arriver."
-C'est ce qui s'est passé
pour vous
quatre ans après :
vous vous êtes attaquée
à la mairie
de Mont-de-Marsan,
un bastion
de la gauche
depuis presque un demi-siècle,
aux mains du même homme politique,
Philippe Labeyrie, depuis 24 ans.
Vous avez déjoué les pronostics
en l'emportant.
Après votre élection,
vos adversaires étaient convaincus
que vous alliez démissionner.
C'est vrai ?
-Oui, mais parce que,
très simplement,
mes adversaires,
c'était le Parti Socialiste.
Ils étaient très machos.
Ils pensaient qu'une femme
ne pouvait pas y arriver
et qu'une femme sans expérience
dans le domaine
n'y arriverait pas.
Moi, je dis à tous ceux
et à toutes celles
qui veulent s'engager
qu'il faut beaucoup travailler.
Les choses ne sont pas arrivées
comme ça.
C'est aussi beaucoup
d'investissement,
certes peut-être des capacités
à comprendre les situations
et à faire les choses,
mais en tout cas,
bien sûr que j'y suis arrivée
et j'ai été réélue en 2014
au premier tour.
-A quel moment
vos adversaires ont commencé
à changer de regard sur vous ?
-Ecoutez, je pense
que M. Emmanuelli,
qui était président
du conseil départemental
et la figure tutélaire
du Parti socialiste dans les Landes,
a reconnu
que j'avais bien travaillé
quand j'ai été réélue
au premier tour en 2014,
donc que j'avais fait mes preuves.
-Alors, il a dit de vous :
"Elle est sans doute plus tranchante
"que moi."
Dans la bouche
d'Henri Emmanuelli,
on peut se dire
que c'est un compliment.
-Je ne sais pas
si c'est un compliment.
Oui, peut-être.
-Il avait la réputation
d'avoir un très fort caractère.
C'était sa façon à lui
de faire de la politique.
-Mais je pense
que je ne fais pas
de la politique
comme lui.
-Vos différences ?
-Ecoutez, lui,
c'était un petit peu
de la coercition
au niveau du département,
qui existe encore un peu,
bien qu'il ne soit plus là.
De la coercition vis-à-vis
des élus, des maires,
tous liés automatiquement
au conseil général
ou au conseil départemental
aujourd'hui
et ne pouvant pas dévier
des trajectoires
qui leur étaient dictées.
Moi, justement,
c'est exactement l'inverse.
Je pense que chacun,
dans une démocratie,
à partir du moment
où il est élu,
il peut s'exprimer
et il faut
que les personnes
travaillent ensemble.
-En 2017,
à peine élue députée,
tout s'est accéléré pour vous,
là encore
de façon un peu imprévue,
on va dire.
Personne n'avait vraiment misé
sur votre entrée au gouvernement.
Pas même vous.
Racontez-nous un peu l'histoire.
-Ca, j'y ai pas pensé
une seconde.
J'ai...
C'était très simple,
Je venais m'inscrire
à l'Assemblée nationale,
j'avais fait
la moitié du chemin.
C'était un 21 juin.
J'avais fait la moitié du chemin,
et puis à 13h, j'ai un message
du cabinet d'Edouard Philippe,
qui me demandait
de passer à Matignon
parce qu'Edouard Philippe
voulait me rencontrer.
Donc, j'ai rencontré
Edouard Philippe.
Le soir, j'ai été nommée
secrétaire d'Etat
auprès de la ministre des Armées.
Je vous avoue
que j'étais partie de chez moi
avec un sac à main
pour la journée
et que j'ai dû rester
quelques jours.
Tout ça est assez...
Tout ça était
totalement imprévu.
-Parce qu'en fait,
à l'origine,
il était prévu
que François Bayrou
et Marielle de Sarnez soient
au gouvernement.
Les choses n'ont pas pu
se faire en l'état
et on a un peu l'impression
que c'est l'effet papillon :
deux petits événements
ont des répercussions
en chaîne
et finissent par déterminer
votre destin
pour six ans.
-Oui. Je reconnais qu'il y a eu
un concours de circonstances.
Un concours de circonstances,
pour moi, assez incroyable
et qui m'a propulsée
dans des gouvernements,
en définitive,
pendant six ans.
Eh bien, voilà...
J'ai donné tout ce que j'avais,
j'ai fait
tout ce que je pouvais faire.
J'ai été à la fois très honorée,
très fière de servir mon pays
et aussi très concentrée
dans la tâche,
dans le quotidien,
mais aussi dans l'avenir
qu'il faut que l'on dessine
quand on est
dans un gouvernement.
Je trouve que bien entendu,
tout cela a été
tout à fait passionnant.
-Passionnant pendant 6 ans.
D'abord, vous l'avez dit,
secrétaire d'Etat
auprès de la ministre des Armées.
Vous avez été aussi ministre chargée
des Personnes handicapées.
Quand l'aventure a pris fin,
qu'est-ce qui a dominé ?
Est-ce qu'il y avait
une part de frustration
de pas pouvoir aller
au bout des choses,
ou une part de soulagement,
avec une fatigue accumulée
au fil du temps ?
-Ni l'un ni l'autre.
Frustration...
Elle hésite.
Peut-être parce que quand on...
Par exemple,
pour les personnes handicapées,
j'ai mis en oeuvre
la conférence nationale
du handicap.
Toutes les annonces faites
par le président de la République,
il faut les décliner
sur les cinq ans à venir,
mais en fait,
je me dis que bon,
c'est bien, la feuille de route,
elle a été écrite et financée.
-Le plus important.
-Je ne sais pas,
il faut le mettre en oeuvre,
après
- c'est ça le plus important -,
mais au moins,
nous avons fait ce travail.
Ensuite, fatiguée...
Oui, c'est usant.
C'est usant d'être
dans les gouvernements,
de faire
beaucoup de déplacements.
Les choses sont usantes,
mais bon...
Donc, ni l'un ni l'autre.
Je crois que j'ai pris ça
comme je prends
toutes les choses dans ma vie.
J'ai eu de la chance
de faire ce que j'ai fait
et maintenant,
j'ai d'autres objectifs.
-Vous avez pris
beaucoup de plaisir à la fois
en tant que maire
et membre du gouvernement.
Tout ça, c'est l'exécutif.
Aujourd'hui, vous êtes
à l'Assemblée,
du côté législatif.
Est-ce que ça correspond autant
à votre tempérament ?
-Beaucoup moins.
-Mais est-ce que ça vous...
L'exécutif est très passionnant.
En définitive,
ce qui peut être intéressant,
c'est la bataille politique,
parce que c'est là
qu'elle se joue.
La bataille politique,
aujourd'hui,
elle est rude.
Elle est rude
parce que nous sommes
en majorité dite relative
et que nous avons
des oppositions extrêmes
qui sont excessivement virulentes,
qui sont même très violentes,
à mon avis,
dans leurs expressions.
Je crois qu'il faut pas
se laisser faire,
parce que, d'abord,
c'est bien injuste, bien entendu.
Ensuite, je pense
que dans ces moments troublés,
la France aurait besoin
d'un peu plus de modération
que de radicalité
et de propos violents.
Donc, il ne faut pas
se laisser faire.
Je veux faire de la politique.
-A l'Assemblée.
On n'a pas encore parlé
de votre attachement
aux traditions du sud-ouest.
Ca peut être la feria,
mais pas seulement.
Il y a aussi la défense
de la corrida, le gavage des oies,
la chasse.
Vous comprenez
que ça fasse débat,
tous ces sujets-là,
dans la société ?
-Je comprends
que tout puisse faire débat.
Ce que j'ai plus de mal
à comprendre,
c'est une espèce d'acharnement
sur, tout simplement,
les habitants de nos régions.
-Pour vous, ça cible les habitants ?
-Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr.
Ils sont discriminés.
On les prend pour des ploucs,
excusez-moi,
pour des gens
qui n'ont pas
de cervelle,
avec une cruauté.
Bon, c'est pas ça du tout.
Nous sommes...
Notre coin est un pays de cocagne,
avec ses traditions, certes,
avec ses modernités aussi,
avec ses évolutions également.
Je m'inscris en faux
quand on décrit...
Par rapport à la façon
dont sont décrites les choses.
-Vous avez peur que ça nourrisse
un vote populiste,
d'interdire la corrida,
par exemple ?
-C'est une accumulation,
si vous voulez.
Des accumulations
d'interdictions
ou de projets d'interdiction
sur des pratiques locales,
qui sont, en fait,
tout simplement
des pratiques traditionnelles
ou des pratiques
culturelles locales.
Les cultures locales,
il faut les maintenir.
Si on pense tous la même chose,
si on mange tous la même chose,
eh bien, le monde n'aura plus
beaucoup d'intérêt.
-On va passer à notre quiz.
Je vais commencer des phrases,
vous allez devoir
les terminer.
"Redevenir maire
de Mont-de-Marsan en 2026,
"c'est quelque chose..."
-De possible.
-Que vous envisagez, donc ?
-Pourquoi pas ?
-C'est noté.
"J'ai l'air austère, mais..."
-En fait,
je le suis pas du tout,
dans ma tête.
Je me marre et je trouve
qu'on se marre pas assez,
d'ailleurs. Ici.
-Enfin, "jaune et noir
"sont nos couleurs"...
-Oui, vos supporters
sont là, debout.
-Oui...
-Voilà.
Mont-de-Marsan est dans nos coeurs.
C'est l'hymne.
-Nos supporters seront là
jusqu'au bout.
Voici la réponse.
C'est l'hymne du club
du Stade Montois.
-Voilà.
-Vous y êtes tous...
A chaque match,
vous y allez ?
-Bah, j'essaie,
mais pendant mes six ans
de gouvernement,
j'ai loupé beaucoup de matchs.
Heureusement
qu'ils sont télévisés.
-Vous allez vous rattraper.
-Oui, je vais me rattraper.
Merci beaucoup d'être venue.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
-Vos supporters
Sont là debout
Mont-de-Marsan est
Dans nos coeurs
Vos supporters seront là
Jusqu'au bout